The Joker has been portrayed
in many movies over the years.
As time marches on, more cinematic
takes on the Joker are created,
and new rules for the character's silver screen
portrayals are established. But despite these
different interpretations, these are the rules
Batman's nemesis has to follow in every film.
The Joker is known for many things:
Dating his psychiatrist, killing Robin,
and even attempting to copyright fish. Yet there's
still one thing that makes the Joker really stand
out on the grim streets of Gotham: His look. The
criminal mastermind is known by fans for wearing
purple with green hair - a color combo that
appears at least once in each film portrayal.
Some Batman villains are also recognized
for their wild style, like the Riddler,
the Mad Hatter, and Polka Dot Man. But as the
years have gone on, Gotham's bad guys have come
to favor monochromatic tactical armor and subdued
gangster suits, in keeping with the noir aesthetic
established in the early comics. By contrast, the
Joker bursts off the page and onto the screen in
colors rarely worn by villains, especially in
movies. When the Joker is on screen with Batman,
the audience's eyes are inevitably drawn to the
circus-y tableau that is the Joker's hair, suit,
and garish makeup. To do the legendary
villain justice, a film portrayal of the
Joker requires a get-up so loud, it takes away
attention from the guy the movie's named after.
The Joker's sense of humor not
only gives the character his name,
but also defines his crimes. The Joker
may have failed as a stand-up comedian,
but he still builds entire evil plots around
punchlines, puns, and one-liners. Sure,
he might be looking to kill you, but the Joker
is also definitely out to make you laugh.
Each new Joker actor is tasked with finding their
unique take on the Joker's particular sense of
humor. Heath Ledger's portrayal in 2008's The Dark
Knight is a sterling example of an actor blending
abhorrent behavior and comedic timing to draw some
genuine, if regretful, laughs from the audience.
Whether it's the dry delivery of a quip
after he brains a criminal with a pencil…
"I'm gonna make this pencil disappear."
"Ta-da!"
...or the dark physical comedy Ledger brings
to the Joker's frustration with a detonator,
the beloved actor set the bar. It's
twisted comedic beats like these that
give the character his staying power. When he's
on screen, no one knows whether to be ready for
something hilarious, something horrific,
or the Joker's own blended brand of both.
Any worthwhile villain needs a theme song.
Vader has "The Imperial March," the shark in
Jaws has John Williams' "Theme From Jaws,"
and characters in any Martin Scorsese movie
have The Rolling Stones. These songs alert
the audience that the villain has arrived.
With the special exception of Jack Nicholson's
art-defacing dance party in 1989's Batman, set
to the tune of Prince's "Partyman," the Joker's
theme isn't a song - it's his devilish cackle.
The laugh, which hits an octave that immediately
registers as maniacal, is so iconic that The New
York Times published an entire feature on the
pressure actors feel to get it right on screen.
Most of the performers who've played the
part over the years credit one man with
mastering the Joker laugh: Mark Hamill, who
voiced Joker in Batman: The Animated Series.
As Hamill revealed to the Times, his
audition script bore an explicit command:
"Don't think Nicholson."
So he drew inspiration from Amadeus, the
Blue Meanies from 1968's Yellow Submarine,
and Dwight Frye's 1930s Dracula movies.
Hamill's performance may only be vocal,
but he set the benchmark for what
audiences think a Joker laugh should be.
The '80s was a formative decade for the Joker and
Batman. Frank Miller's The Dark Knight Returns and
Batman: The Killing Joke by Alan Moore and Brian
Bolland gave the Caped Crusader a new and gritty
edge that would come to define his corner of the
DC universe. Miller's work focuses on the dark,
long-term relationship formed between the
two men, having them fight to the death
in a Tunnel of Love ride. Moore and Bolland's
tale explores the insanity these characters share:
Where Batman stares unblinkingly into chaos,
the Joker has flung himself straight in.
These depictions didn't just give audiences
an interesting new conflict - they also turned
Joker into a nigh-perfect Batman villain, who is
the hero's opposite in nearly every sense. This
dynamic has vividly colored how movies portray
the relationship between these foes. No matter
who plays him, the Joker will do anything to sow
chaos, and Batman will do almost everything to
stop him. Even in 2019's Joker, Arthur Fleck has
a conflicted connection with young Bruce Wayne.
While the villain acting as the hero's dark
mirror is a well-worn trope, it's rarely done
so perfectly. Audiences are always entertained
when, as Ledger's Joker says in The Dark Knight,
"...an unstoppable force
meets an immovable object."
While the Joker might not be able to bring
himself to kill the man behind the cowl,
he'll certainly knock off the people closest to
the Caped Crusader. Even when he's not targeting
Batman, it's the Wayne family he's after, such as
the grudge he holds against them in 2019's Joker.
Ever since comic fans voted for the
Joker to kill Jason Todd in 1988,
movie adaptations have heavily leaned into the
personal toll he exacts upon his foe. In 1989's
Batman, the Joker is the man who murders Wayne's
parents. In 1993's Batman: Mask of the Phantasm,
the Joker almost kills the love of Batman's life.
In 2000's Batman Beyond: Return of the Joker,
it's revealed that he kidnapped Tim Drake, comic’s
third Robin, and brainwashed him as a child to
grow up to be the next Joker. Most famously, in
2008's The Dark Knight, the Joker kidnaps Batman's
childhood friend and old flame, blows her up, and
in the process, makes Harvey Dent into Two-Face.
At this point in the filmography, Joker is
the grand marshal of Batman's tragedy parade.
The movie franchise has explored many tones,
from camp to thriller noir to pure action.
The characters need something to ground them
through these many fluctuations - something
audiences can immediately grasp. The Joker
threatening Batman with the loss of loved
ones is intimately recognizable to anyone,
no matter who's in the director's chair.
Many great actors have portrayed
Bruce Wayne over the years,
but no matter how talented the
performer in the batsuit might be,
whenever Batman and the Joker share the
screen, the actor playing the Joker upstages
his pointy-eared counterpart. Take 1989's
Batman: Jack Nicholson's manic charisma fuels
an iconic performance that draws attention
from Michael Keaton's reserved Bruce Wayne.
When news broke that Heath Ledger would
be cast in the role for The Dark Knight,
angry fans decried the decision, but later
changed their tune. Upon the film's release,
legendary movie critic Roger
Ebert described Ledger's Joker as,
"The key performance in the movie."
He followed that sentence by predicting
Ledger's posthumous Oscar win.
The potential for prestigious actors to run
away with the role has become so entrenched
in the zeitgeist that Todd Phillips built
his entire standalone Joker film around
Joaquin Phoenix's bizarre, difficult,
and ultimately Oscar-winning performance.
Unlike some beloved characters,
the Joker's aesthetic and attitude
adjust to the current moment. By contrast,
Batman may receive some suit upgrades,
but he retains roughly the
same tabulation of grimaces,
batarangs, and tactical leather. The
Joker evolves while Batman stands still.
Jack Nicholson's Joker dances to Prince,
and his gang's coordinated berets, Ray-Bans,
and parachute pants give their enterprise a
distinctly late-'80s sense of chic. In Batman:
Mask of the Phantasm, Hamill's Joker wears a
sleek purple suit and a dangerously toothy grin,
in keeping with the retro noir
aesthetic of the '90s cartoon.
Something interesting happened in 2008:
Heath Ledger's Joker is notably grimy looking
and also adopts a criminal attitude that
reflects the era's post-9/11 fear of terrorism.
Recently, the Joker's portrayals have shifted
for a generation that grew up with the internet.
Jared Leto's Joker in Suicide Squad is a Patreon
page away from being a criminal influencer,
while Joaquin Phoenix's Joker taps into societal
fear of the sort of lonely, disenfranchised men
who have become closely associated with
the darkest corners of the internet.
Part of the Joker's appeal is his
status as the ultimate wild card;
he is likely to betray anyone and anything at a
moment's notice. From comic appearances to the
small screen to the silver screen, portrayals of
the Joker excel when he's acting unpredictably.
His status as a villain allows writers the freedom
to have him make choices the hero never would,
while his reputation as a maniac keeps everyone,
even his alleged allies, on their toes.
When he's not throwing his own henchmen
into harm's way for self-preservation,
he's setting Two-Face loose on the same men who
paid the Joker to kill Batman. Or, if he's keeping
it simple, he's burning mountains of cash. In an
interview with the BBC, director Christopher Nolan
explained how the Joker's sporadic behavior was
baked into every aspect of Ledger's performance:
"A lot of it was about unpredictability,
and I think he wanted to
play his cards a little close to the chest."
That sort of mystique makes a
villain instantly fascinating and
endlessly watchable - even if done
through eye-shielding fingers.
Any cinematic portrayal of the Joker
worth its salt features a grand entrance.
These arrivals aren't just cool - they also
announce the Joker's presence in a grandiose way
that immediately raises the narrative stakes.
For example, Ledger's entrance in The Dark Knight
is a tightly constructed double-cross. By
the time the final bank robber realizes
that the Joker has instructed all the
men on the job to execute each other,
the audience has a clear idea of the type of Joker
they're dealing with. Ledger's Joker is a madman,
yes, but the opening robbery also demonstrates
his ruthless intelligence and calculated plotting.
In Joker, Joaquin Phoenix's complete take on the
character doesn't arrive until the third act.
When he does finally appear in full regalia,
his entrance isn't punctuated with a fight
scene or a heinous crime. Instead, it's
a dance number. Phoenix's Joker debut,
set to Gary Glitter's "Rock and Roll Part 2,"
couldn't be more different from Ledger's reveal,
however, both entrances set new
standards for grand Joker arrivals.
Humor alone does not, a good Joker
make - he should also be terrifying.
While the Joker is an inherently
vivacious and charismatic villain,
his staying power comes from the way
he blends that charisma with horror.
Consider the hostage tape/snuff film the Joker
sends Gotham news stations in the first act of The
Dark Knight. With its homemade style, purposefully
amateurish editing, and its unmixed audio,
the terrifying tape appears to have rolled in
from another movie. It's deeply disturbing.
Later, when Ledger's Joker holds a dinner
party hostage on the hunt for Harvey Dent,
everyone on screen and in the theater feels
their palms sweat as they become aware of
the Joker's intentions for his victim. It's
moments like these that are essential to the
character's power over moviegoers. Plenty
of villains have flair, many crack jokes,
and most have an army of dispensable goons
who rarely receive first and last names.
But the Joker is one of those special villains
whose bark is worse than his formidable bite.
The Joker's ability to evoke a visceral response
from the audience whenever he's on screen
is what has ingrained the character in the
public consciousness. Fans of every age
remember childhood hairs standing up on the backs
of their necks when they hear his sinister laugh.
There's one fundamental rule movie portrayals of
the Joker must follow that trumps all the others:
The Joker can never kill Batman.
One of the most interesting things
about the Joker is his desire
to keep his arch-nemesis alive.
He even admits as much in The Dark
Knight's interrogation scene, saying,
"I don't want to kill you,
what would I do without you?"
For most villains, this approach would really
deflate the danger they present to the hero.
In contrast, the Joker's desire to continue
the fight makes him seem even more dangerous.
The never-ending struggle between Batman and the
Joker has become part of the franchise's appeal.
The Joker often remarks that life without Batman
would be boring, and the audience can't help but
feel the same way. He is constantly finding ways
to almost break the Bat, and thus, constantly
finding new ways to keep audiences interested.
This homicidal will-they-won't-they dynamic makes
their relationship truly one-of-a-kind,
and fans everywhere are grateful for it.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Batman are
coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.